this program is brought to you by the
emory university center for ethics hi
I'm Kate Powell and today I'll be
talking with John banja a medical
ethicist with the Emory center for
ethics and a professor in the Department
of Rehabilitation medicine he has
authored many publications including the
book medical errors and medical
narcissism that's a tough question it's
a tough question because we really don't
have good data on what doctors or
medical directors or whoever is doing
the the disclosure of air on what they
actually say to patients or family
members what I mean is we're not in the
room with them when they do they're
their communications and their
conversations about this stuff and by
the way these are anguish conversations
I mean if we're talking about a serious
medical air that hurts somebody this
it's probably the most difficult
conversation that a healthcare
professional can have so I think that we
are however doing better in that you
know for just about all of the 20th
century physicians were instructed by
their the risk managers of their
hospitals their practice carriers their
insurance companies to not disclose
error because it was thought that that
was an invitation to a lawsuit still is
by the way but I mean that was the
ideology of the 20th century if you
committed an error you did not tell the
patient about the air or a mistake you
did not apologize to them now we're
starting to think though that of course
not only is that unethical because
individuals have a right to know when
they've been harmed by a negligence in
error but we're also thinking that that
idea of concealing or stonewalling has
actually led to maybe more medical
malpractice suits than it has prevented
with regarding a question I think
organizational leadership is very
important this is what we expect we
expect truth we expect honesty and and
and also by the way we will support you
rather than our first op our first
response being to blame you and to
punish you so that's one thing another
thing is that the error disclosures need
to have the skill set in order to
disclose error it is amazing what will
come out of an individual's mouth when
he or she is nervous frightened feeling
miserable and feeling embarrassed and
feeling humiliated I mean this is a huge
huge obstacle that anyone trying to
communicate or disclose a medical areas
going to run up against namely the
embarrassment the humiliation the
theater that you're going to get sued so
so we need to help healthcare
professionals develop that skill set and
we need to support them and and and you
very much need everyone to come on board
with this we need the malpractice
carriers you need the hospital attorneys
you need leadership and you need the
medical staff to to all come together
and say yes this is the right thing to
do and we're going to do it as best we
possibly can first of all
I have come to appreciate the fact that
very very frequently in fact virtually
always medical errors are very
complicated in that it doesn't seem to
be complicated when the physician
operates on the wrong side of the body
or or or the nurse gives a patient the
wrong medicine yet when you ask yourself
well how did that come to be how did
that how did it actually happen that
that nurse gave the patient the wrong
medicine and you do you start doing
what's called root cause analyses to
find out how did that error happen
that's where you begin uncovering the
enormous complexity of how these errors
occur you can have an error that occurs
and yet it doesn't necessarily have to
harm somebody it's it's the harm causing
air as though that should really and
dramatically attract our attention
although any error really really should
for that matter so that's that's that's
one set of issues that we have to do in
terms of training but the other one I
think that you were talking about is how
do we develop a sense of conscience in
health care professionals and it cannot
begin to early I mean I can give a
lecture to third year medical students
about the need to be frank and honest
and ethical and transparent and blah
blah blah and all that kind of stuff but
let that medical student actually
observe a physician disclosing error in
a less than Frank less than honest less
than transparent way and my hunch is
that we'll have much much more much
greater impact on the development of
that individuals professional
personality and
and self than all the lectures that I
can give him or her
the preceding program is brought to you
by the Emory University's Center for
Ethics